- Hi.
- How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] How are things?
- Things are all right.
- You good?
- Yeah.
- What up, my guy?
- How you doing?
- How are you?
- Good, man.
- How are you guys doing?
- [Tee] Good, man.
Trying to adjust to this weather.
We coming from the west coast.
It was hot out there.
- Yeah.
(hip hop music playing from a phone)
- Yeah, basically, his album
is gonna drop May 11th,
then you guys are on the same mind wave.
Like, I was just telling him,
perspective, humble, gratitude.
The way he looks at things
is literally like preaching.
You know what I mean?
And, he's from Detroit.
He quotes Eight Mile.
About Eight Mile and stuff.
- My whole thesis on life is
the last scene of Eight...
Literally, my thesis of
life is the last scene
of Eight Mile, which is,
if I tell you all the shit
I suck at, what you got left?
- Yeah.
Right.
- That's literally how I think about it.
Tell your truths of all your shortcomings.
Like, this.
This is my report card.
I put it in a frame and I
make sure everybody sees it.
Ds, Fs, worst in class.
- Damn.
- Yeah, that's a real report card.
- Where you find this at?
- I actually had my assistant
reach out to my high school.
I was like, I get the rights
to my report card, right?
You need to send it to me.
Look, I got four As in
high school, all in gym.
Everything else is Ds and Fs.
- I know why, bro.
I gotta tell you, this view is crazy.
- [Gary] Crazy, right?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] It's funny.
I picked it 'cause Madison
Square Garden is there.
- Which one is...
Oh, right there, yeah.
It's hard.
I like this view.
- I appreciate it.
You come through New York a lot or no?
- I'm here often.
I'm here often.
- Yeah.
So, tell me what's going on with you guys.
Obviously, album focus is real, right?
- Yeah.
- Definitely about to
drop an album, May 11th, called Activated.
- Activated.
- And, I chose
the name Activated 'cause I feel like
everybody get activated
in they own way, you know?
But, in my way in particular,
I always wanted to be able
to buy jewelry, always wanted some money.
I always wanted to be like a
rapper, a respected rapper,
in the industry, you know?
I always wanted to showcase
my talent and people, like...
- And, when did you know you had
the potential skill to actually...
You know, so many kids wanna
be athletes and rappers
and business people.
How early were you, like, wait a minute,
I think I could actually do it,
not just wish I could be it?
- Right.
Now, I always rapped, right?
- [Gary] Yep.
- But, it was like...
- And then, people,
from right away, were
like, oh, you're bad.
You got it.
- Yeah.
The people from...
- Right from the get.
- Yeah, but it never went
no further than that.
- Right.
- So, it was something missing.
- Like 99 point nine percent of people.
- Yeah.
It was something missing,
so I'm like, okay.
What I gotta do?
I don't know.
I'm dropping the best music.
I don't know what to do.
So, I get locked up.
- And, how were you
dropping it back then?
- I was dropping it on YouTube.
I was just making songs.
- YouTube.
- Dropping them on YouTube.
- SoundCloud, too, or not at that time?
- No, I didn't know
nothing about SoundCloud.
All I knew was YouTube.
- Understood.
- So, when I got locked up, right?
- And, how old are you now?
- I just turned 24 on March 23rd.
- Okay, and you got locked up when?
- When I was 19.
- Okay, keep talking.
- So, I get locked up, off the rim,
my first time going to prison,
I was in a whole different State,
very far away from home, in Kentucky.
And, you know, you get
to talking to people,
you get to mingling, and
you get some emotions
out there going.
I was out there rapping at social hour.
Oh, let me hear something then.
So, I would rap for 'em.
I would rap for some to them
that anybody in the city loved
and they was like, no, brother.
That ain't it.
And, I'm like, damn.
I'm like, maybe that's what's missing.
Damn, this is why I don't
connect with anybody
because this is some super Detroit shit.
- Yeah.
- You know?
And, they was critiquing me.
I got locked up in so
many different States
and this one time I had a taste...
- [Gary] Oh, they kept moving you?
- Yeah, they kept on moving me.
- You built your fan base
and you literally crafted it
and got context that makes
so much fucking sense.
- Look, I'm like, okay then,
you don't like this type of music, here.
What can I do?
How can I make it more universal?
- How many times did you get moved?
- I got moved about five, six times.
- Did, by the third time,
you were like, wait a minute.
This is a good thing
'cause I'm gonna craft
and hone my craft.
- Yeah.
- Like, the first time, it's like, fuck,
but, like, the third
time, like, wait a minute.
- The first time, I was
so far away from home.
I didn't know nobody.
I didn't get no visits, nothing.
It's just crazy.
But then, I'm like, wait.
This is an opportunity.
I'm gonna be, ooh.
And, they like, this is
why we don't like it, bro.
The stuff you talking about, I respect it,
but we don't know about that down here.
You rapping about old schools.
We don't like that.
We like newer cars.
Everybody dreams about getting a new car.
You're rapping about old school.
Can't come down here and
be successful like that.
Rap about stuff that's universal.
Don't rap about stuff
that's popular in your hood.
- [Gary] That's right.
- You know, all you rap about is...
All you need to rap about is
what you think people like.
Everybody don't like violence.
Everybody wants some money, though.
Everybody wanna have fun.
Everybody go to parties.
So, put more energy into is
and put some more thought into...
- And, were you writing the whole time
or you just go from the
dome or how do you do it?
- No, I was writing and
going from the dome.
I do both.
I really write in my head, when I write.
I don't never use my phone,
unless I'm gonna feature.
- [Gary] You're like this.
Like this, okay.
- I'm like, boom.
Okay, so, repeat that a million
times, so I remember it.
- Just to yourself.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I love that shit.
- But, basically, just
moving around just helped me
critique it and become more universal.
- How long were you locked up?
- I was locked up for
three years, all together.
- And, how did that feel when you got out?
Happy?
Took a little while to get situated?
- It felt surreal.
It was, like, say if they told you
it's another planet.
- Yeah.
- It's another planet.
It's just like earth, but 10 times better.
You're like, your lights don't
never have to get cut off.
There's so much energy.
Wakanda.
And, it's like, when you
get there, okay, boom.
You go next and they see you up there
and now, you're just here, you're like...
I don't even know how to feel.
When I first came home...
- Did you go
back to Detroit?
- Yeah.
- I didn't know how to feel.
I saw people was all
caught up on Instagram.
I ain't been on Instagram in so long,
I really ain't care about it.
- [Gary] It changed it every day.
- You know what I'm saying?
I don't even know how to work it no more.
I don't even like Instagram no more.
I don't know how to work it.
Then, they trying to hit me Facebook.
I'm like, hold on.
That's super complicated.
Only thing that stayed the
same, for real, was Twitter.
- That's right.
That's the only thing
that stayed the same.
- So, I'm on Twitter or whatever.
- You came out and you went right to music
as soon as you got out?
- Came out, soon as.
'Cause, look.
It's like this.
I got kicked out of college
and they told me I
could come back in 2018.
I got out 2016.
They told me I could come
back 2018, so I'm like, okay.
I'm a try the rap thing and
if the rap thing don't work
by the time I can go back to
school, I'll go to school.
- I get it.
So, you gave yourself a time limit.
- Yeah, I'm like, I'm not going back,
'cause that ain't for me.
I don't wanna go to it.
That's not for me, you know?
I'm like, prison, that ain't for no people
who trying to make a
better life for they self.
I feel like that's for,
like, people that need help.
Real rehabilitation.
You feel me?
So, I'm like, I'm not
going back there at all,
so it's either rap and get a job
up until I go back to school.
That's all I'm gonna do.
Soon as I first came home,
first day out, first album that dropped.
Took off.
- Really?
- Yes.
- That's the best, man.
You didn't have to wait, even.
- Man, didn't even have to wait.
- Where'd you put it?
On YouTube, too?
- Yeah, I put it on YouTube.
- [Gary] And just went?
- Yeah.
My parole officer: oh,
you need to get a job
or I'm locking you back up.
I'm like, yo, I gotta get a job.
I started working at this golf course.
I started the video the first day out.
I ain't had no money.
She had to pay for everything.
Video, outfit, everything, you know?
So, we did that.
Video came back, she sent me the video.
I'm like, watch, see how I look.
I watched that video about 12 times.
I was like, dog.
That's my first video I ever shot, too.
I'm like, damn, I finally got a video.
Okay, I'll wait to upload it.
A lot of people don't even know I'm home.
I wanna surprise them.
I want this video up.
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Man In Red] It went crazy viral.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Got this guy in the game
at that moment and Jay Visa's aunt.
And, when we spoke with Jeezy.
we were talking about how you should
work with more of you guys.
This is the guy that
Jeezy really is, like,
fucking with super heavy.
- What a feeling.
- Definitely.
- This one is aimed
at a blessing.
- Yeah.
- [Man In Red] So grateful.
- Yeah, for sure.
Definitely.
I feel like...
- So, what happened after that?
- Off of the song?
Off of the song, I dropped
the song, like, a week later,
I started noticing I'm starting to get
a lot of Instagram attention.
I'm like, wow, suddenly,
I got work this, here, G.
People out here saying.
I'm getting all these
followers on these DMs
and people like, oh, you
rocking with John and R Kelly,
you rocking with who in New York.
I'm like, damn, you all are
going crazy over my shit.
I'm about to damn near drop another one,
so that's just going.
Next thing you know, 21
Savages shoot me a DM.
I'm like, dog, 21 Savages
DM'd me right now.
He's told me, I wanna bring you out.
To ring him up and be sitting right back.
I go perform with them.
All type of other celebrities
DM me for my number.
I'm on FaceTime with them and they say,
you know 21, call him back.
Yeah, I'm about to go on tour.
You ready, I want you
to come on tour with me.
- [Gary] Fuck.
- Went on tour with him and
it's just been like that
ever since then.
It's still, like, moments.
I look up, Lebron James rapping a song
or Jay-Z shouting me out on interviews
or little Instagram famous
females got the song
playing in the background
while they dance.
Lots of people like that.
That's just crazy.
Shit moving.
- So, now what?
What are you guys debating as a crew, now?
What's the big decision next?
- The big decision is,
basically, what to do
to move the culture.
Like, what to do to, like...
'Cause, firstly, I'm not gonna lie,
I really, like, shook the culture.
A lot of people was...
Dog, it's like, I believe in what he said.
I like his music a lot.
So, I basically just try to
keep on reaching out to people
outside of music, talking
to people, going to school,
go in to these schools, building
relationships with people
and just, you know, drop the best music.
- That's cool.
What do you think?
- I think, Tee is something different
and special and fresh
in the music industry
and he has a lot to offer.
What I like about him
is that, I'm gonna say,
99 point six percent of what
he's rapping is his life
and it's true.
- Yeah.
- It's what he's going
through, what he went through,
what he's going through, and what he...
- [Gary] Is about to go through.
- Yes.
And, that, you know...
- [Gary] Truth wins.
- It all wins.
- Truth fucking wins.
- You can tell it's authentic.
- Yes.
The authentic-y, yes.
It's definitely there and
I think he should collab
with some different things.
- To get awareness in other pockets?
- Yes.
- You guys are friends or
are you part of the crew?
What's the story here?
- Friends.
- You live in Detroit?
- Yes.
- You guys grew up together.
So, you think he should
collab with things like,
as rogue as EDM artists and country
or you mean, like, just
pockets of hip hop.
Not so much like Atlanta or,
how are you thinking about it?
Just curious.
- I would put a cap on it.
I think he should collab...
- [Gary] How do you think about that
from a music standpoint?
- I feel like it's
definitely a move to make.
It's just that this is all new to me
and, as I understand, I'm really...
- This came quick.
Listen, I get it.
I'm listening real carefully, man.
That's why...
You know, I know enough.
I know the things you're talking about,
but hearing them from
you and your perspective
is the only way that I can
really understand it, right?
- Yeah.
- People watch from the outside.
You know why I have this?
'Cause when I tell people,
like, yo, I was a bad student
and you can do this, they don't believe me
because once people see success,
they don't see the shit beforehand.
I'm like, no, seriously, I
fucking failed all my classes.
I'm one of the best public
speakers in the world.
I got a D is speech.
- Yeah.
(audio cuts out)
- To give a fucking talk
and I got a D in speech.
15 year olds need to hear that
because I thought I was shit,
or at least I didn't, but they
tried to make me believe it.
- Yeah.
That's lit.
- Are you doing a good
job taking a step back
and really, to yourself...
That's a lot, fast.
- Yeah.
- That's like from zero
to hero real quick.
- Yeah.
- You need to be care...
I don't know you.
Some people can handle, you know,
but that's something...
Honestly, just hearing
you say it makes me happy
'cause I'm like, okay, good.
He's thoughtful about it.
- Yeah.
It's like, I be taking the
time to myself to think,
but it be like...
- There's so much happening.
- So much be going on, you
barely get time to think.
- Yeah, as soon as you
try to start thinking,
some crazy person's DMing
you or phone's ringing,
somebody's got something to do.
- I give him back your
time, but didn't you just
rent out the theater for the
kids to see Black Panther?
- Yeah, maybe three hours.
I had two theater for my old
middle school, high school.
- [Gary] That's what's up.
- So, go see it like that.
- You've done a good job, my man.
That's exactly right.
- I appreciate that.
- Do yourself right
and do them right.
- But, it be like, you
be having another thing,
you have a lot of people
you want stuff from
or take stuff from.
- I got a sports agency, now.
Me and my brother.
You got cousins you never heard of.
People just make up
stories of fourth grade
when I took care of you.
What are you talking...
People just making shit up, these kids.
- What?
- I've seen DMs.
You know, like, yo, you're
about in the league.
Don't forget your man.
These are people...
People, like, I didn't
even go to school with him.
- Man, that's crap.
No, that happened.
Even I was like, okay,
everybody who I ever robbed,
I'm paying y'all back.
Now, I know who I robbed.
- [Gary] People like, yo, you robbed me.
- People that didn't even go to the school
to watch me rob.
It be crazy.
- [Gary] You really did that?
You went back in your head
and made whole with all those people?
- Yeah, I paid 'em all back,
but I knew who all it was, though.
- Of course.
- Because, I was only targeting...
- Were they surprised?
- I don't know.
Honestly, I didn't see they face.
They got the money back, it
was like they had no contact.
- [Gary] Got it.
- I just paid, gave
the money to the State,
and they gave it to them.
- [Gary] I got it.
- But, it be like...
- Got it.
- It's just, like, I don't know.
I can't explain it.
- [Gary] How did we get connected?
What happened?
You hit him up or...
- I've known her for,
maybe, almost about a year.
I'm happy we found her.
- How did you
guys get connected?
- Through Kei, one of Savage's managers.
- She's amazing.
- Kei was like, hey, Mike
and Gary are great people
and JB is the person to know,
so they just connected the dots
and, I mean, without a doubt...
So, I'm from the Midwest, too,
and without a doubt, you
know, this is the guy.
- [Gary] I know what's going on.
- He's the new guy and he's honest
and that's what everyone in
the Midwest wants to hear.
No one wants to hear anyone lie.
- [Gary] That's what everybody
wants to hear, period.
- Yeah.
- New York, Cali, Atlanta.
The truth is always
gonna win the long game.
You can fake people for a minute.
- Yeah, I like that.
(everyone laughing)
I like that.
- You know?
- The crazy thing is I
heard you talk about someone
fixing a problem and he
does reverse engineers,
you know what I mean?
Like, to the extreme.
- Sorry,
I don't know that one.
- Alexa, stop.
- And, that's like Gary's whole thing.
That's why, on the way in here
- Start with the finish line,
- I was telling him.
- Go backwards.
Every thing I do is to
buy the New York Jets.
Professionally, everything.
And, everything I do with
my content and everything
is to have a legacy so the
world stops when I die.
That's it.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] My family life,
I've got that mission.
I've got my black and
white business thing,
which is like, buy the fucking
Jets, win some Super Bowls,
and then, I've got my,
kinda, like, this part,
which is, like, leave a legacy,
have interesting meetings,
say one thing that might
help a kid, help a person.
You know?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] So many nuances to every story.
I don't know, I'm gonna
put this on YouTube.
I get 10 emails a day of
people watching my content
that are locked up.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] It might be some guy
sitting right now, some gal,
you know, and just be like, wait a minute.
You literally sat in here and said,
I saw the opportunity in my situation.
That's the fucking game, man.
- Definitely.
I mean, man, when you in there,
that's a whole other world.
It literally is a whole other world.
- I don't know, but I know.
You know what I mean?
- Even the language
learned, like, you know,
when I go back to the
world, I'm a do this.
It's a whole other life you live in there.
When I first got to see how people move,
I'm like, damn, I'm really locked up.
And here, it's aggressive.
Real aggressive.
Say, me and you, like, was
sitting at this table or whatever
and I just grab your
pen and get the woo woo.
Now, out here, it's put it back.
Okay, everything good.
If you do that in there, you
getting butchered, literally.
- Yeah.
- And then, when you come home
and people be trying to reach out to you
and they think, oh, he changed
or prison made him bitter,
but it's not like that.
It's like, I can't reach
out to you when I'm in there
and you know where I'm at.
You didn't reach out to me for a little
while I was in there, so when
I come home, I gotta go now.
I'm not about to reach out
to you or even reach...
We went three years without talking.
What's to talk about?
- I get it, man.
Your situation's double bonkers
because there wasn't a
lot of time in between.
You know, it's even hard...
It's real easy if you were
locked up for three years,
back in Detroit for 15 months,
and then shit started popping,
then you could have audited.
Nobody even had a breath.
You didn't have a breath,
they didn't have a breath.
- Yeah.
- If you're talking
about the timing you just...
I didn't real...
I knew.
I heard a story back...
But, I thought there was more time.
- No, no time.
It was like a week.
- So, I got empathy,
actually, for both you
and that other party
that I don't know who we're talking about
'cause there was no time.
- It was no time.
It was literally like a week, two weeks.
- That's heavy, man.
- So, the other weird thing is,
how you were so bad in
school, he was great in school
and he went to college and was gonna...
- Imagine people seeing us.
They'd be like, who was bad in school.
- You know, I heard you
say you were gonna work,
you were sitting down, you were interning
and gonna do the finance thing.
You're actually like a smart...
- Yeah, you're a school smart guy.
- Smarter than most people.
- I get it.
- So, you got the whole thing.
You could really teach kids...
So many kids look up to
you, probably hate school
and you could be like, yo, I love school
or you know what I'm saying.
You can say whatever you want, but...
- Tell him your grade point average.
- I don't know, a lot
of my shit was up there.
I had like a three eight.
- And, got a full ride to Michigan State.
- That's fucking crazy.
What'd I get?
I got one point six seven.
You know what my class rank was?
I was ranked 243 out of 254.
That's what's up, man.
Michigan State.
Full ride to Michigan State.
Good for you, man.
Listen, Detroit's real interesting.
I'm real friendly with Dan Gilbert.
- I used to work for him.
- Is that right?
- I'm dealing with him in a couple weeks.
I'm actually thinking
about opening offices.
Detroit is on the short list
of VaynerMedia's next office.
I love what's going on in Detroit.
It's such an easy flight from New York.
It's like boop boop, you know?
It feels just like a drive, you know?
It feels so close, you know?
- Yeah.
- I always thinks it's a different time...
New Yorkers always think
Detroit's a different time zone.
Every time I land, I'm like, oh, no.
(Tee chuckling)
All right.
Go ahead.
- It's also
about building relationships.
When you mentioned Dan Gilbert.
So, with that relationship, there,
we're shooting his next video
in one of his properties.
You know what I mean?
So, we wanna build relationships
and keep them strong
while we're building his brand.
- What do you want to happen?
What are some of the
pillars you wanna win,
besides music, from an
entrepreneurial standpoint?
- Honestly...
- Yeah.
Too early to even really
think about it that heavy?
- No, I'm just gonna
give you like a glimpse.
Okay.
My whole life...
It be so hard for me to have
these type of conversations,
'cause I understand what it's like
when it's time for me to
put something on the table.
It be like, damn, 'cause my whole life,
I was never exposed to
no business, no legal...
- I get it.
- You know what I'm saying?
So, I'm really just not learned
and talking to you is like,
okay, you know X, Y, and Z.
So, by you getting to know me,
you could tell me which route to take.
- I got you.
We'll do some real homework.
I understand.
It's the same way...
Listen, I grew up that way.
Listen, I didn't go to business school.
I know exactly what you're talking about
and, honestly, my core
friends group in college...
I went to Mount Ida College.
All my friends when to prison, for real.
I really understand what
you're talking about.
So, I get it.
My friends made their money selling weed
and robbing people and
playing C-Lo and fucking...
I get it.
- Yeah.
- I really understand what you're saying.
I mean, I look like I
understand what you're saying,
but I really understand.
- And, once you send me a route, too,
I be so committed.
That's why I was about to
get the Ursa Young thing,
'cause, like, okay, when
I finally got a glimpse
of Ursa Young and it's like,
they telling me who they are
and what they have to offer
that's all I knew about, so I'm like,
I'm gonna try my best to just,
like, crush this, you know?
So, every day, I'm just emailing the lady,
the recruit who come,
every day I'm emailing her,
whenever she come on campus,
I'm taking her to lunch
and stuff like that.
- [Gary] At Michigan State?
- Yeah.
You had to have a certain GPA
and you had to be an
essential profile look.
A month before, I didn't do none of this,
I didn't meet the requirements or nothing,
but she liked me so much.
- You charisma-d her.
- Yeah, then she allow everybody who come,
you gotta come to Chicago
to the Global Perspectives conference
and you get entered into the
Alliance program internship,
but I ain't have no money up there.
I got no family, no support,
no money, none of that,
so I'm like, damn, what am I gonna do.
I just gotta go for what
I know at this point,
so I could try to get
this to get to Chicago
and ended up getting called up.
- That was it.
That's how it went down.
- Yeah.
- Fuck.
- I get it.
Listen, man, thank God life is long.
- Yeah.
- Right?
(laughing)
- Thank God life is long.
I'm glad we met.
This was real enjoyable.
- [Man In Red] Yeah, and it's
so cool that he's so honest
about every single angle.
- Honestly, you know this.
You know how many...
And, you probably know this.
I do a lot of these 10s and
15s, but let's do a dinner.
- [Man In Red] Yeah.
Hell, yeah.
- This one, I wanna build on.
When you gonna be back through New York?
- [Man In Red] Hunter's in New York,
but how often are you here?
- When the next album gonna be out?
- We can come as soon as you need us.
- Yeah, it is super close.
Am I in meetings?
All right, let's talk.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
May 11th, he's about
to chill everyone one.
- Yeah, we gotta be ready for that, too.
We'll give that some exposure.
- I appreciate it, bro.
Nice to meet you.
- Real pleasure, man.
I really like your vibe a lot.
- Thank you.
I appreciate it.
- My guy.
Been a pleasure.
I'm glad we met on the
lay of the weigh in.
- I know.
- I love this wall.
I was over at Chris Brown's
house, at his studio, set up.
He's just got so much collectible stuff
and to come here and see this.
This is probably...
I need to do something like this,
with all the stuff I like.
- [Gary] Get over here,
let's take a photo.
(upbeat music)